what's going on everybody welcome to the
fifth Python with matplotlib for data
visualization tutorial video in this
video we're going to be talking about
stack plots so the idea of stat plots is
to kind of show basically the size of
use or the relative I don't know
percentage of something or in the whole
so you usually are you going to show a
stack plot to convey both a you know
holistic number and then also within
that holistic number you're going to
have you know the sections that kind of
comprise that holistic number so if that
sounds confusing maybe I'm doing a bad
job so let's go ahead and just show an
example so let's say you've got some
information and you've got
let's do days we'll say days and this is
you know your days so 1 2 3 4 & 5 so
we're going to log 5 days of stuff and
then what we're going to say is you do
stuff during the day so let's kind of
you know compile the things that you do
in two major categories so let's say
sleeping uh sleeping eating working and
playing make these lineups so we know
what we're doing now sleeping let's say
I don't know what a typical human sleeps
will do 7 8 6 11 and 7 so in order they
slept 7 hours and 8 hours and 6 hours
they made up for that with 11 hours and
then 7 hours eating I don't know I get
all my energy from the Sun so 2 3 4 3 &
2 that'll do working let's do 7 8 7 and
then the weekend hits let's say and they
just work 2 & 2 and then playing you
play for 8 hours this day 5 7 8
and then 13 so these should add up to 24
if they don't that's too bad and the
next thing that we're going to do is
we're going to do a stat plot
so do stat plot will do PLT dot stack
plot and we stack plot the basically
you've got your first you got your X so
the x-axis will be days and then you've
got like all your Y elements and they'll
just stack on top of each other in this
order so we'll say sleeping eating
working playing okay so those are the
the Y elements let's say and then
finally we add colors if we want you
don't have to but we'll do it and we
need four colors so we'll go with
magenta we need to put these in strings
so we'll go with magenta cyan red and
black okay so that tree gives us a stat
plot so we can save and run that and
there you go we're calling a legend uh
so that's kind of why we got that error
again but luckily for us looks like we
add up to 24 every time so that's good
and then we can kind of see here where
we're spending our time now part of the
problem with this is that we don't
really know what each element is right
we don't know what's this black what's
this red what's this blue or the cyan
and what's the the purple what what are
these so we have to close everything and
we wonder you know can you have like
labels or something as stack plot as far
as I know the answer to that is a big
fat no and the reason why is in stat
plot and really everything that you have
a what's called a fill that's where you
have a line and then everything is
filled under it so these are in
matplotlib terms these are polygons
anytime you have a situation like that
you can't have a label I'm not sure why
but you just can't so so you can't do it
but luckily there is a kind of way for
us to handle for this and that is with
making fake plots okay so why matplotlib
just doesn't do this in the background
when we have a stack plot I don't
no but it's just the way it is so let's
say you're in a situation where you're
doing the stack plot and you want to
have a really anything so later on we'll
do fills too and it'll be like a fill
between a number and a number we won't
be able to have labels there either so
if you want to have it anyways how might
we get around doing that well we can
plot empty plots so we could do
something like this
PLT dot plot empty list empty list and
then we would have a label all right so
let's add a color first let's do color
equals and then we'll have that magenta
and then we'll do the label equals and
what corresponding to the this magenta
well sleeping so that label would be
sleeping okay so then we can take this
line let's just copy and paste it copy
paste paste paste so four times well
paste three times and then you've got
eating and then we had working and then
we had playing and then our colors would
be magenta cyan red and then k4 black
and now what we can do is let's save and
run that OOP ways an L K for black try
again and now we can at least have some
you know fake lines here now
so this is our sleeping but it might be
kind of hard to see so one thing we
could change is like line width for
example so that's another parameter
we've not really talked about yet so use
a line width equals let's do five and
just kind of add that to all of them now
they're a little thicker right in our
legend and so that worked for us so now
we can see while we're spending all this
time playing and then here we're
spending a lot of time working then the
weekend hit not so much and then also
when the weekend hit apparently we're
spending less time sleeping and so on
anyway later on you might want to you
know this is like these half days right
like 2.5 3.5 4.5 that is actually
totally meaningless right to our graph
and almost is kind of confusing like
like
we were maybe on on day 4.5 we were
doing this much so you might want to
remove those but we'll be talking about
that more in detail when we actually go
do our customization of matplotlib but
for now that covers stack plots now the
next tutorial will cover pie charts
which is kind of like stack plot so
anyways if you have any questions or
comments on this tutorial please feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time